إنها واحدة من ألمع الطهاة الشباب في البلاد ،
لكن بالنسبة لمالك
كارولين جلوفر وطاهي أنيت ، فإن أحد المطاعم الأكثر سخونة في منطقة دنفر التي تقدم
الفلفل الحار
وسلطة البيض هي أقل ما يقلقها ،
فهي دائمًا ما تكون في مؤخرة
موظفيك الذين يقومون بالتوظيف ،
ونأمل ألا يقوموا بالتوظيف  يتسبب معدل البطالة المنخفض في
نقص كبير في العمالة في المطاعم للطهاة القفاز
وغيرهم من الطهاة في جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
لا يوجد عدد كافٍ من العمال لغسل
الأطباق
وخلط الكوكتيلات والطهي للرواد في
صناعة المطاعم الصاخبة ،
كل شخص هنا يكتسب الكثير
من الوزن
و  لديهم الكثير من المسؤوليات
، لذا إذا لم يحضر هذا الشخص أو
استقال ، نشعر أنه ليس هناك
وسادة مناسبة لذلك فهذه حساسية من الفول السوداني ،
لذا قامت ببناء واحدة في نخب تاناتو منحدر
جميع المكسرات الأخرى على ما يرام رغم
أنها تدفع لها  الموظفون نفس الأجر مع
جميع الإكراميات مقسمة بالتساوي بين
العمال
بغض النظر عما إذا كانوا نادل أو قفاز
غسالة
صحون يقول إن ذلك يعمل  لكل شخص
يكسب ما بين 25
و 30 دولارًا في الساعة ، فنحن نحتفظ بالطهاة
أكثر بكثير من الكثير من المطاعم الأخرى
، وهو مرتبط بشكل مباشر
بهيكل الأجور الذي
يجب على الجميع أن يربحه نفس
المبلغ من المال
لأن الجميع ضروري في هذا
النظام الضخم.
أكبر مشكلة في
الصناعة ، يعتقد لاري ديجريس مستشارًا
للعديد من سلاسل المطاعم في جميع أنحاء
البلاد
أن معدل البطالة الوطني المنخفض
وشيخوخة السكان
وزيادة الوظائف مثل
قيادة السيارات المشتركة قد ساهمت في
نقص كبير في الأشخاص المستعدين
للعمل في المطاعم
وخاصة  مرة أخرى في المطبخ
الخلفي للمنزل ، تكون المهام جسديًا
تتطلب مستوى مختلفًا من المهارة
من أجل أن ينجح
هؤلاء الأشخاص ، من الصعب العثور على
دفع
كل شخص بنفس الطريقة التي تم تعديلها
للموظفين في
Annette حيث يحبها غسالات الصحون على ما نحن عليه
هل نتقاضى رواتب جيدة حقًا
لفريق الانتظار ليس بقدر ما
حصلنا عليه بالتأكيد من رد الفعل من الإرسال  في
حين أنهم قد لا يجنون الكثير من المال بقدر
ما يمكنهم في المطاعم الأخرى ،
تقول القفاز إن معاملة موظفي الانتظار
باحترام في بيئة إيجابية
هو ما يبقيهم على اتصال بالإنترنت
ولكن ليس لديها خطط لتغيير سلم الأجور ،
فمن الضروري أن تكون كذلك
تنافسية والحفاظ على مطبخها
يعمل بسلاسة. rihanna keeler cnn